Hales guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to the seventh episode of my flappy bird
series today we'll put everything we've
done so far to practice by drawing an
object so what kind of code do we need
to draw a triangle in opengl three plus
we'll need three basic things to
accomplish our simple goal a vertex
array a projection matrix and a shader
program in fact we can even drop the
projection matrix let's start with the
vertex array so what our vertex arrays
in OpenGL a vertex array is basically an
object that stores an array of vertices
vertex arrays can also store other data
such as normals colors texture
coordinates or literally any data you
provide it with at the bare minimum we
need vertices to render objects in
OpenGL let's hop into our main class and
import GL three zero we'll also go ahead
and import GL to zero since we need that
for shaders to create a new vertex array
object we simply type GL GL vertex
arrays and assign the ID we get to an
INT i call the end VAR which stands for
vertex array object as you saw with
textures last episode we need to bind
the object before we can use it
so let's bind our vertex array now that
we've effectively selected our vertex
array object we can render it by calling
GL draw erase with the mode set to GL
triangles the first vertex being index
zero and the amount we want to draw
being three since three vertices make up
one triangle that's it
now if we run our game you'll see
absolutely nothing what our code has
essentially done is create a new vertex
array object and then render it by
sending it started to the graphics card
the graphics card has no clue what to do
with the data it gets though so our next
step is to program the graphics card and
tell it what to do with the data it
receives so how can we program the
graphics processing unit or GPU by using
shaders that's how shaders are a
fantastic addition to OpenGL that allow
us to run code on the GPU and since the
graphics card is optimized to run many
of the graphics related algorithms we
want to implement it's insanely fast so
let's go ahead and set up the two
shaders we need let's right-click our
project and create a new folder called
shaders this will contain all the
shaders we'll use for our game
now let's right-click our shaders folder
choose new and file to create a new
empty file I'm going to call it shadow
doc vert with the vert static for vertex
shader and honestly doesn't matter what
name or extension you give the file
since we'll be reading its text I'll
also make a new file called shadow dot
frag which will be our fragment shader
let's open our vertex shader since
that's the first shader that will run
the vertex shader will be run for each
vertex so in this case three times per
render call our mission is simple
position these vertices up the top will
put hash version 334
which will use the core profile of GLSL
version 3.3 which matches up nicely with
our opengl 3.3 version call will not let
us use any of the deprecated code from
previous OpenGL shading language or GLSL
versions like any program there needs to
be a main method to define the entry
point of the program to create it we
simply create a void method called main
now we're not actually sending any real
vertex data from the CPU to the GPU in
fact the only thing we're sending is
that we want to render triangles and
three vertices that's it that vertex
data does need to exist so let's just
create it in our vertex shader we'll
make a constant vector array which will
hold three two component vectors one for
each vertex
since we haven't specified any kind of
projection matrix the bounds of our
screen horizontally are negative one to
one left to right and vertically
negative one to one bottom to top and
near to far is also negative one to one
so let's create three vertices that lie
somewhere with
bounds I'll create one is 0.5 common
negative 0.5 one at negative zero point
five comma negative 0.5 and one is zero
point zero comma zero point five there
we have it
three 2d vertices now we can output them
for rendering by setting GL position to
that array with the index we want to
render being GL vertex ID vertex ID will
be either 0 1 or 2 because when we call
GL draw arrays we specified the count to
be 3 that's basically it
the only problem is the GL position
wants a 4 component vector not the two
component one we specified so let's
convert our vertices vector into a
vector for by passing an intervention
struktur and adding the two additional
components we need for Zed I'll put 0.5
and we'll leave W as 1.0 that's it our
vertex shader is complete inside our
fragment shader I'll set the same
version and create the same main method
fragment shaders run per fragment or
basically per pixel our job here is to
set the color of each pixel that makes
up our triangle firstly we'll need to
actually output a color so I'll type out
that for color outside the main method
each component of this vector holds one
channel of color from 0.0 to 1.0 with
the channels being RGB a inside our main
method let's set this car to be a nice
blue by specifying 0.2 0.3 and 0.8 as
the RGB values and we'll leave the Alpha
is 1.0 to make our triangle fully opaque
that's all the shader code we'll need to
type back in main dot Java we need to
load and activate this shader once
loaded by calling shader utils load with
the file paths of our two shaders and
assigning the result to an integer to
enable it we simply need to call GL use
program with the ID of our shader now
our shader is enabled and we're drawing
our vertex array let's launch our game
look at that a blue triangle mission
accomplished
thanks for watching and I hope you guys
enjoyed this video as always a like is
greatly appreciated next episode we'll
be creating a class for handling the
shaders in our game and setting up our
projection matrix goodbye